le ministre délégué à l'enseignement
supérieur et à la recherche monsieur
alain devaquet a présenté hier son
projet de réforme des universités qui
pourront désormais sélectionner leurs
étudiants à créer leurs propres diplômes
pour ne citer que les mesures les plus
importantes de ce texte il n'a pas été
toujours très bien accueillis notamment
par les présidents des universités
s'estimant privé de concertation mais
avant de discuter avec monsieur de
vaquer je vous propose de voir avec yoba
grégoire comment les étudiants accueille
ce projet de leurs ministres ce matin
l'université de tolbiac la préoccupation
des étudiants se portait plutôt sur
leurs examens mais le projet de loi
provoque tout de même des réactions sur
les points qui les concerne en premier
lieu les droits d'inscription qui
désormais seront fixées par les
universités à priori j'ai j'ai été plus
rassuré sujet cru ça serait plus fort
que ça exactement 6
qu'ils augmentent d visuellement les
droits d'inscription pour l'instant a
pas l'air d'être le cas là moi je fais
les inscriptions joie les réactions des
étudiants et un accord doivent payer
1000 1500 francs il ya un certain ses
ballades pas évident pourront simplement
livre social au niveau financier c'est
complètement délirant si ça creuse
encore plus l'écart 2
des populations à l'université là on
voit quand on inscrit les étudiants on a
à peu près il ya reprise et pourrait
qu'on attende ouvriers que selon les
droits d'inscription augmentent depuis
qu'en plus on a une sélection sur les
mentions au bac c'est bien clément vague
se font uniquement une question trail
105 et sans culture
en effet dans le projet des universités
pourront choisir leur bacheliers sur
certains critères
une forme de sélection qui fait peur à
certains mais qui ne peut pas totalement
nouvelle pour autant je pense qu'il ya
tellement de changements parce que déjà
les choix pour l'entrée à l'université
il ya déjà des universités qui pratique
et ça a tant donné par exemple ados
filles prennent uniquement les bac avec
mention
bon alors d'accord va légaliser tout ce
à quoi çà se faisait déjà son sans être
vue du public à thal bien que beaucoup
espèrent que les pratiques ne changeront
pas et qu'on acceptera toujours les
bacheliers sans discrimination côté
enseignants la place prépondérante que
reprennent les grands professeurs au
sein des conseils fait tiquer
particulièrement ceux appartenant un
dessin du plein d'éloges c'est de voir
que l'on est en train de redonner à une
catégorie d'enseignants
je sais que dans la presse on les
appelle les mandarins ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens car le mandarinat est
beaucoup plus à mes yeux un comportement
une affaire de diplôme ou de titres on
est en train de donner tout de même à
cette catégorie
d'enseignants chercheurs de l'empa qui
sont tous enseignants chercheurs
évidemment en étendant leur donner une
un pouvoir qui ne correspond peut-être
pas complètement
quelle que soit la qualité à jeudi à
leur poste et 6 6 devant l'université
ici l'attitude générale semble ce matin
plutôt modéré face à un projet qui ne
donne pas aux universités l'autonomie
totale et la concurrence entre al que
certains attendaient et que d'autres
pouvaient craindre